só sei a esses quinas por que passei
só eu sei sou eu se esquinas dos
desafios ou t em cada esquina que
dobrava sinalizavam inspirações para uma
caminhada revolucionário que eu queria
na minha vida
cada vez que eu for falando vá visitando
as esquinas que representaram pra vocês
desafios já sabe que o meu nome regina
célia filha de jorge da silva edvaldo
vieira da silva que lhe ensinaram que é
a perseverança um dos motivos
necessárias para que prosseguisse para
que definisse uma marca no último out o
que eu fiz de treinamento 81 minutos do
desafio é para 18
meu pai era militar da marinha capixaba
minha mãe professora de jovens e adultos
rio grande do norte
meu pai filho de construtor e de uma
dona de casa semi analfabeta
minha mãe filha de costureira o meu pai
enquanto não queria ir trabalhar com meu
avô das construções era obrigado a
servir a toda a comunidade no morro da
fonte grande em vitória do espírito
santo como eu queria trabalhar com o pai
então vai servir a todos da comunidade
fazendo compras ou carregando água
quando isso não bastava para minha avó
que castigava montado e limpar o
banheiro de tal forma
dizia a ela que eu possa depois almoçar
aí é detalhe
minha volta um calmo sua mesa com o meu
avô e os meus meu pai e os meus tios
porque a mulher comia depois que todos
tivessem sido servidas
enquanto isso minha mãe estava lá em
natal sendo criada por uma costureira
que foi casada com o homem em razão de
uma dívida de jogo que o pai dela tinha
contra a o meu avô pai do meu avô meu
bisavô u
a minha avó então foi a última coisa que
o meu avô tinha para atacar como
pagamento de uma dívida de jogo
ela então casa em 1910
aos 13 anos de idade e dos 14 anos aos
32 anos ela teve 23 filhos com muita
raiva porque como o meu avô não gostava
dela queria focar apenas uma vez
minha mãe então filho desta mulher é uma
das caçulas uma das últimas e fez parte
do projeto paulo freire de pé no chão
também se aprende a lei
o meu pai quando ele estava há 15 anos
resolveu sair de casa se alistou na
marinha
lá foi construir fez parte da primeira
escola de aprendizes marinheiros de
vitória no espírito santo
logo depois a construção dessa escola
meu pai ficou como barulho pra limpar os
banheiros da marinha e uma vez numa
inspeção comandante então chegou lá e
viu o banheiro tão limpo tão limpo e
perguntou quem era aquela pessoa
mandaram chamar e naquela e simplicidade
da década de 60 o comandante então
mandou trazer à mesa as cadeiras e disse
que a reunião vai ser feito aqui
quando meu pai chegou ele fez um
levantamento do perfil do meu pai e
disse você vai embarcar no navio com a
gente no navio em que meu pai foi
embarcado limpando o desafio meu passa
pela estação rádio e ouvir o barulho das
máquinas e telegrafia funcionando
chega lá não tem telegrafista vai ver as
fitas e quando vai ver as fitas lendo as
mensagens ele vê que é uma mensagem de
sms de calção azul e camiseta branca
testada tudo e vai até a casa do com até
a sala do comando e na sala do comando
então o o comandante desesperado por ver
aquele marujo com aquelas fitas meu pai
diz o que é não compreender o meu pai
nem as fitas confirma o ss atendendo
navio quando retornou para o rio de
janeiro
meu pai é preso então numa audiência
estavam ali sobre a mesa dez fitas e o
comandante então leia todas as fitas e o
meu pai leu todas as fitas e preocupa o
comandante quem foi que lhe ensinou como
telegrafista meu pai desse não compondo
então a ele a história de que ele era
obrigado a servir os vizinhos a via
email um radioamador que pagava o meu
pai ensinando a ele a ler as fitas e
telegraph
o comandante então mandou escrever em
meu pai na escola de telegrafia e foi aí
então que meu pai foi a natal conheceu a
minha mãe e ao conhecer a minha mãe
então se casaram em 1968 ano da
revolução 15 de junho nasceu regina
célia com os meus pais eu aprendi a
educação mas a escola não me ensinou que
os meus pais me ensinaram nas esquinas
porque passei por muitos desafios e como
diz mário portela ele disse que as
famílias confundem escolarização
educação porque a família para educar é
lotar uma punho fundamental as escolas e
os meus pais deram muito apoio no meu
primeiros momentos de bullying já da
polícia o meu pai então chorando estava
chorando e meu pai então disse minha
filha você tem que saber que logo ao
caminho tassey sala a casa grande não
fique no meio do caminho não se perca
mas se conseguir tente tente mais uma
vez não pare não volte prossiga
pronuncia vá o mais longe que você puder
minha mãe completava dizendo que eu
deveria fazer o impossível porque
mediante a história da minha avó que
sofreu violência doméstica e quando meu
avô foi preso então delegado perguntou
pra ela o que a senhora acha que a gente
tem que fazer vamos mantê-lo preso ela
disse não pode soltar mas apenas lhe
garanta que nunca mais ele passará a
soleira da porta
porque eu sou maria ferreira de almeida
e a cada nova experiência que eu passo
ela só vai fazer sofrer uma vez porque
isso sou eu que decido o que deus
determinou a minha mãe então com base
nessas palavras da minha avó também
inspirada dizia pra mim você pode tudo
minha filha mas só faço o que você puder
mas enquanto você não souber o que fazer
faça então o impossível e foi impossível
conseguir fazer os direitos humanos
através da educação a educação para mim
transforma é uma motor é um combustível
forte de enfrentamento à violência que a
violência ela não é uma manifestação do
extinto a violência ela não é
circunstancial
a violência tabela não é um dado preciso
a violência irracional ela é premeditada
na violência se ensina e se aprende é da
violência onde existe uma pedagogia
a pedagogia do oprimido minhas raízes
trouxeram pra mim um processo de
construção da identidade ou de eu tenho
muitas inspirações entre elas rayet
tubman conhecida como as foi géis dos
negros norte-americanos e rayet falava o
seguinte o fogo negro queria desistir se
ouvir tais continue civil tochas na
floresta continue se ouvir gritos atrás
de você continue nunca pare o chile
se você quer sentir o gosto da liberdade
meu pai quando eu me acordava ele dizia
pra mim que deus salve a rainha e quando
fazer aniversário ele dizia vida longa à
rainha as minhas inspirações vieram de
palavras palavras que transformaram em
uma revolução uma das mulheres que me
inspira como revolução rosa parks você
nunca deve ter medo de fazer o que é
certo e eu não tive medo quando eu
conheci maria da penha maia fernandes
eu trabalhava no programa brasil
alfabetizado pernambuco 2006 309
mulheres a fato assassinadas veio em
nenhuma inspiração criar um prémio maria
da penha e quando fui falar para os
amigos eu vou criar o primeiro da penha
mas eu preciso de maria da penha pra que
ela possa é garantir o nome pra que ela
possa provar o nome ao prêmio pessoal
você tá louca
kaká só se você for uma sessão espírita
por que você não sabia maria da penha
morreu eu falei dão que está ali ao lado
do ex do presidente lula e da ministra
ellen grace recebendo no é a honra de
ter o nome dela no a lei 11.340 06 é
maria da penha não é ali uma irmã dela
eu disse bull não pode ser em janeiro de
2007 o google duas e trinta e oito da
manhã
eu só coloco o número do celular de
maria da penha maia fernandes e aparece
apav associação dos parentes e amigos
das vítimas de violência
fale conosco e coordenação ao lado tinha
maria da penha maia fernandes número do
celular naquela madrugada até o meio dia
mas não dá para 7 horas mas ninguém pode
ler ligar pra uma pessoa às 7 horas da
manhã muito menos se não conhece eu não
liguei
mas liguei e 7/15 às 7 15 então liguei e
uma pessoa atendeu a lo
aí eu falei se a lo aqui regina célia de
recife pernambuco eu queria falar com
maria da penha maia fernandes ela disse
sou eu
maria da penha maia fernandes da lei
11.340 06
ela disse é maria da penha maia
fernandes que está ao lado do presidente
lula e da juíza ellen grace ela disse é
disse ei
a minha boca eu te encontrei o meu deus
meu deus a proteção que foi o que foi
eu falei nada nada nada me diz o seu e
mail diz que a embratel porte onde o que
importa é que isso aconteça
me diz o seu email e ela me deu e meio e
eu mandei todo o histórico em 5 e meios
para maria da penha
falando sobre a realidade 2009
eu e maria da penha fundamos o instituto
maria da paz com o programa que eu criei
defensora defensores dos direitos à
cidadania
esse projeto foi contemplado pelos
norte-americanos eu fui aos estados
unidos apresentar o projeto e de 2010
pra cá o instituto maria da penha tem um
apoio o governo norte americano para
realizar ações de enfrentamento à
violência contra a mulher
o instituto maria da penha não era uma
realidade quando eu mandei o projeto da
maria da penha ela disse mulher o que é
isto
eu disse é o instituto penha e que vai
mudar o mundo vai mudar a realidade de
crianças e de mulheres
como é que você sabe deus me inspirou
eu dobrei a esquerda e na esquina havia
um caminho e o caminho dizia o último
lhe a minha identidade é construída em
cima disto de inspirações de idéias que
vem e o trabalho isso da perseverança
por isso eu acredito que de onde vim às
minhas raízes falam gritam lobão e diga
continue
visite o espaço de sua mente ou de
instalar ainda as suas raízes não
interrompa você não tem que interromper
nada daquilo que você tem certeza do que
deve fazer
nada e tudo o que você vai fazer vai
alcançar em espiral mente inúmeras
pessoas das quais você nunca conheceu
mas que você sabe que são vulneráveis o
suficiente para não acreditarem em si
mesmas mas que você tem ralis suficiente
para acreditar que você pode fazer com
que aquele fruto possa prosperar com tim
eu falo isso aos meus alunos há 21 anos
como professora universitária formada em
filosofia e mestre em ciência política e
fazendo o doutorado na universidade de
coimbra aprovada aos 47 anos de idade
eu fui aprovada neste doutorado que não
é a distância é presencial mas 3.200 com
44 anos eu apresentei três vezes esse
projeto da universidade federal de
pernambuco e ele não foi aprovado
eu não conseguia entrar o mundo então
ciado pra qualquer um de nós nos
desertos que atravessei meus valores e
as convicções foram todas relacionadas
mas eu não parei o contínuo e estendo a
mão para que todos possam vir comigo e
continuar o enfrentamento à violência
minha avó disse ele.o decidir só sofri
uma vez deus determinou eu não quero
mais esse homem em 1954
minha avó morreu em 1988 firme e
decidida
sei os muros da casa grande e sei como
voltar para aceitá-la
mas pra lá só volto para resgatar
aqueles que ainda não têm consciência de
que estão presos na escravidão da
submissão da baixa auto estima e da voz
em favor dos que não podem defender esse
seja o defensor de todos os desamparados
é que a voz e julgue com justiça e
defenda os direitos dos pobres dos
necessitados
o seu direito continue muito obrigado
[Aplausos]